[Music]
welcome back to ladies night at jk
we got to know that there isn't enough
women on the show so we decided to bring
more women for you guys i decided to
bring this [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] did this happen dude this
wasn't even planned [ __ ] there's nine
people here
record we i don't think we've ever had
nine people this is [ __ ] we're making
history right is this even going to be a
good conversation no way it's gonna be a
terrible amazing no it is not even gonna
be a conversation we're just gonna ask
one question and we're gonna get david
to answer it all right and it is the
burning question that you had a hard
time for some reason all right let's
don't make it too real dude don't make
it too real you want to ask him go ahead
that's about the edited complex
you absolutely created it it's not my
style guys you created it all right
you're the one that thought of this stop
yelling at me stop telling me everybody
wants to know would you rather [ __ ] your
mom or your dad gun your head oh easy my
dad dude why are your dad why is he it's
almost hella mean
[Laughter]
but then turn over please
[Laughter]
remember he was like [ __ ] he said do
your dad missionary and i was like oh
god that detail is terrible
you have to look into his eyes dude
huh have you ever seen your mom naked
before you looking at me
because you're a freak dude
i think i was one of the ones that like
stopped showering with their moms later
in life last year
like yesterday nah maybe like eight is
that too old
that's pretty old that's kind of all
right showers are so big is it because
she
is it because she insisted
is it because your mom is like so
forceful she's like no you need [ __ ]
come here scrub my back a little [ __ ] i
think it was
one or the other she didn't trust me
because at night when i'm watching tv
she wants me to take a bath right and
then i'm so glued to the tv i only take
showers during commercials so i have to
be in parts so i'm running to the
bathroom
watching i'm watching tv and i still
have soap in my hair what the [ __ ] and
it's commercial go back rinse it and
then come back and maybe have some soap
like right here so i'm doing i'm
breaking it up into parts so you just
have this wet trail leading from your
room to the bathroom and we also had
that plastic thing that you put over the
carpet you know i'm talking about yeah
with the spikes underneath on the other
side yeah oh homes don't have that
anymore nah that's gone damn
they stopped saran wrapping their
[ __ ] remotes really wait you surround
wrapped your remote right chad
hey filipinos
could agree to everybody
it's like hey what oh my gosh
yeah please you guys never did that [ __ ]
dad put that [ __ ] in a [ __ ] ziploc
bag and then he taped the ziploc bag
together yeah why what's the point to
keep the remote [ __ ] pristine but
then you just look like a crazy person
with everything like no longer alone
[ __ ] yeah why not cause my dad's
[ __ ] insane would your remotes get
dirty all the time no our remote's
numbers and everything just faded
exactly
but that's that's sign to just buy a
universal remote at radio shack do you
guys remember those old tvs where the
remote was like this big yeah dawg that
[ __ ] was ridiculous it was an ipad
though
i like the big remotes where you had to
be like it would be a thing that you
could get like hot topic or some [ __ ]
sometimes see that big remote do you
remember the tv that would explode the
tv that would explode when you turn it
on you press you press the on button and
it goes
yeah and every channel is too much
[Laughter]
it's got that like nice meaty feeling
hey welcome to 1940s guys
none of you guys can relate it all born
that time it's just our [ __ ] poor ass
grandparents kept that [ __ ] you made it
too real man
but that's when it's fun
i still don't understand the plastic
wrap thing though no it's to keep the
it's to keep the remote clean so it'd be
like oh so you know like you spill water
on it won't like [ __ ] the remote up or
whatever but what's the limit to what
you're not wrapping like it's wrapping
not even just saran wrap if i went to
like a more rich vietnamese house they
had actual plastic remote sleeves that
had like colored with like leather on
the side yeah
you would literally take it you put the
whole remote and you [ __ ] velcro it
and it would be a remote cover my mom
had homies that would saran wrap the
steering wheel
wow
why don't you come in and support my
conversation i'm not gonna ever back you
up
i'm not gonna ever be talking for five
minutes
the whole time he's relating he was like
man that's around wrapped everything
he's like i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
weirdo so i guess we're done with the
whole [ __ ] your parents conversation
that was a good answer such an easy
honestly it was like just uh hawk what
would you do oh no
this is a normal person
oh
god what's your on song
[Laughter]
dude bro by the way action ever by the
way this is your onslaught this is
happening as a hostage situation yeah
but the
the guy who's going to kill you all is
he's going to make you seduce one of
them but they don't know why
yeah because you got to convince them to
have sex with you yeah you have to
convince them but you can't tell your
parents like hey i have to [ __ ] you or
still going to kill us yeah you just
have to start you just have to go start
going like this
you gotta be easier
okay you have to either finger your mom
or jack off your dad easier
oh
it's kind of like jacking yourself off
through time yeah all you could make
through a different generation
yeah to jack yourself up exactly
but what if you have to hear his moans
and [ __ ] well then that's the version
[Laughter]
hey grab ryan's shoulder huh look at my
shoulder whatever dad does this
talk to me like
looking through my eyes
i had my mom grab my shoulder man
what if he's like sound effects please
you should just try to moan over him so
you're up the hero oh
no that was that one's easier though
that one's easier which one is dad
yeah jacking off rather than [ __ ]
well yeah because that's probably never
you know
it's all been backed up by his son
i
i don't think so either call your dad
right now see what he wants
[Laughter]
don't even bring mom into the picture oh
my god
why is it either oh just go for it anger
your mom that no it's a loaded question
no why
no
am i the only one
you care about your dad more than your
mom
no i think so
it's just closer to jacking myself up
because i'm the opposite of you i would
[ __ ] my dad all right not my mom
because i don't like him so i'll [ __ ]
him
angry
but i'd finger my mom and not jack off
my dad because he is getting no pleasure
from me
you think he'd be happy while you're
jacking him up yeah why would i [ __ ]
make him come
he doesn't get that my mom on the other
hand she's been around us joseph
[Laughter]
you've been there all my life you
deserve this you deserve dude i [ __ ]
finger pretty good so you deserve it
what if your dad jacks you off at the
same time
no because i hate him so you're sharing
the present you guys will both be fine
it's all pixelated anyways you can't see
anything
but that only happens to japanese people
that are born in japan okay
all three of us you could see our
uncensored things that would be so funny
dude japanese people when they take off
their clothes
[Laughter]
today's video is brought to you by
upstart it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when you have
high interest debt and sometimes it can
be even harder to ask for help and
that's when upstart comes in upstart
powered personal loans can help you pay
down high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you're
more than just your credit score so
rather than just looking at your credit
score alone upstart's model considers
other factors such as your income
employment and other information
provided on your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you could check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to up to 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com off the record to check your
rate today don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based
off your credit income and certain other
information provided on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record let me let me okay i gotta up the
ante okay so you say i'll jack off your
dad right not your mom yeah let's say it
has to be oral now
dad or your mom because genetically it's
the same
most angry british person
that's disgusting mom
so you switch inside no no no no no no
because like you're not gonna suck your
own dick i mean some people do i guess
are you being homophobic right now
not on this channel
i would rather that's true
it's far from jacking yourself close
your eyes and eat some [ __ ] and think
it's just [ __ ] exactly until you hear
your mom moan that's disgusting oh god
it's good that we have nine people in
here to talk about this yeah add three
guys in the conversation let's see how
intellectual we get well why were you so
quick to pick your dad too to [ __ ] my
dad yeah
oh cause i'm not gonna touch my mom
that's crazy oh yeah that's crazy
but i'm gonna [ __ ] cheer on my dad
i'm gonna [ __ ] my dad
i'mma beat them cheeks but how would he
react what's he like when he's who cares
dude
you gotta save mom right you know what's
better dude what would you rather [ __ ]
your mom or one of your sisters jesus
you gotta do one right now
i'll pull the trigger for you
at that at that point it's just like
it's it's triple murder homicide suicide
well everybody gotta go
you don't have a choice though you're
one of them you have to yeah you better
do it right you guys are all immortal
three two one answer
you guys have eaten a mermaid so you're
not [ __ ] drunk you're all immortal
vampires live with this for the rest of
your life right
oh man
answer now damn it i no
this that's the thing is like wait
you're the guy with the gun yeah i can't
think about it i gotta really think
about this this is this is a really
important [ __ ] thing to think about
important [ __ ] this is literally
gonna drag this out to the video editor
you can choose wrong you can choose
wrong and you just have to choose no
because i'm really actually weighing it
out on my head i'm literally weighing it
out who's thicker
oh
i don't want to take that into account
because that's not going to be an
account in my
which one of those are better
you got your mom has better better tits
or your sister the dun family is very
flat chested dude
no there's another knot
i have a better i might have the biggest
tits of the fan bro is your mama better
[ __ ] your sister has a way better
juice oh man you know
see that's a thing i think i think me oh
god dude this is crazy this is wild
you're making it too real dude this is
super wild but dudes in west virginia
are watching jk news like dude you guys
are like
man these guys got it all figured out we
do this every day bro i can't do both
i think i'd i'd probably chop my nuts
off dude no no no no
you're immortal you're immortal
it'll grow back you're immortal
so there's no [ __ ] there's no
repercussions like you can do the [ __ ] i
want you to highlander man yeah there's
always repercussions man and it's oh
fine your mom is in her 20s now no that
doesn't make it better dude that doesn't
make it bad you could be your own father
i can't i bro i can't i can't do
anything she's not in her 20s but your
sister is your mom's age
i can't do anything to my mom i gotta
save my mom okay okay all right
oh god yeah i guess so
what a [ __ ] freak
[ __ ] outta
don't you have here than one sister so
fun he wants a threesome with his sister
he wanted a threesome
anybody else in the room got sisters ah
anybody
no well we all know steve's cake that's
not like yours man dude i don't think
steve would [ __ ] a sister though
like the hottest one yeah well he
already did
one what the [ __ ] really yeah he loves
his sister like hardcore yeah she's
pretty hot yeah okay
you can't choose between them though i
already picked my answer dude i like the
uh
i like the last jk clip that we cut up
was when we asked nick if he would [ __ ]
his mom or his dad
and then the thumbnail is
and my face is like this
and then the text was yeah i'll [ __ ] my
dad
and he he had the smallest response in
the video it was mostly anthony
but then he's the thumbnail of god and
it was it was all in a way to get
anthony answer because he's like i don't
want to answer this and i was like dude
easy answer i'd [ __ ] my dad you know he
was trying to like you have a sister
have a sister
you do your turn dude your turn now
i just feel like the only two guys that
never answered
are right here chad's a guest sister
though yeah yeah we're talking about
sisters dude sister let's go yeah mom or
sister go
i hate you guys
see it's different huh this guy was like
laughing on my face now it's on youtube
what are the stipulations everybody's
immortal my dick will grow back
what age is everybody
just give me the [ __ ] hey bring up
the oedipus complex again the same age
they are right now
your sister's juicy's ass right now your
mom's wrinkles but
wait
yes add juicy in there
don't worry we're coming back around for
the brothers okay the eyes juicy
eyebrows
juicy t-shirt juicy pants juicy triceps
juicy j
what a juicy cookie
oh my gosh all right what's the answer
you guys are gonna let your families
down right now dude like you're taking
forever to [ __ ] choose how dare you
there's a psychopath with a gun not all
of us hated our fathers all right well
you know what
some of us grew up with love
but i love my mom and i said i'll eat
her out
[ __ ] i hate you guys yeah probably so
he's about to say he's by saying
either way you're going to get judged i
i know you're sick oh you sick [ __ ]
yeah
what yeah
he said
say it louder bro sister [ __ ] monster
sick [ __ ] who would [ __ ] their sister
that's disgusting i knew when i saw that
goatee was a freak he's a [ __ ]
he really have to pick
yeah
that's [ __ ] nasty i'm serious about
wanting to know jesus
literally david wasn't even on the call
sheet today
what about a beautiful cousin what about
your theater
all right here's here's a real question
right it even comes before this oh good
here's the real question if the guy's
pointing his [ __ ] gun to your head
right now and he goes you have to get
hard right now for your family member
right now this whole family's just
standing there
or your family just you got you have a
lineup of your family member this guy's
trying to really get into that right now
he's really trying to get he's hard i
don't think you have honesty
okay oh you have to pick who you're
getting hard for you have a lineup of
your all your relatives your family
members just standing up in a lineup and
you have to choose one to get a boner
for this scenario makes less sense
yeah
it's so abstract makes perfect sense
guys get into real guys get too real all
right hold on how do we arrive here
all right i will take this back because
you're just gonna admit who you're
[ __ ] horny for but
which which cousin you would [ __ ] first
okay so i guess the question is i think
he wants to tell us which cousin
it's okay you can tell us you can tell
us let me tell you guys right now yeah
for example mine's kimiko how about you
a japanese cousin
it's the most japanese name ever too
that's tight
[Laughter]
we won't judge you now you go
we'll go in a circle i'll go again have
you guys ever been attracted which
family member that subscribed to the
channel would you [ __ ] you no dude i
don't have any females i've never been
attracted to a cousin before a second
cousin dude i am so lucky i don't got no
hot family members
you don't really know yeah all my
cousins are boys so i've never had the
scenario so what about you shut up dude
[Laughter]
how about you
i've never
been attracted to any of my cousins
right but i had a friend oh i know this
[ __ ] that was attracted to his
cousin he wished they weren't related
and then we went over to their house for
thanksgiving the cousin wasn't there but
i saw family pictures and i was like i
think i'd be attracted to my cousin
i could relate
and i can empathize some amount of
empathy
he was like man she wasn't my cousin oh
i'm taking on a date when you're too
young and you don't know you also don't
know what to do with it so it's not like
you're [ __ ] five years old planning
your game
well what to do with that boner yeah
you're gonna say boner is tight
oh no it's all classy dude i've always
wanted this accent on purpose
it's just so smooth do you have it on
accident it doesn't sound right
i'm like an idiot
all right trust to say boner
distinguishedly bona
we'll
can you say this guys i want to see if
it sounds different if you say all right
say i'm a sexual molester
[Laughter]
as opposed to what kind of moles take
one go ahead
uh as your yeah i'm stepping in
it's okay with that what's a sexual
molester dude it sounds nice
like is there a non-sexual cause yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] is that like a
violent fighter
i don't know i wanted to go back to
where joe's like okay imagine this right
your family's looking at you
you got them all laid out
everything's pixelated you have to
choose which dick is yours
game show format
dude japanese porn game shows are the
funniest things on [ __ ] earth what's
what are you saying
where you gotta you gotta see if it's a
girl or your mom yeah
i'm not sure if they still do this but i
saw this years ago they have like this
uh cutout and you just put a [ __ ] in
there right and this guy just starts
[ __ ] every single [ __ ] oh no and
then he turns around
it's the wildest thing ever dude it's a
real [ __ ] it's the person's on the
other end
it's like a glory hole it's a glory hole
but then it just does and then you just
go away and you go baby baby and then
it's like which one is your mom and then
you start crying afterwards i feel like
they've done every idea possible that
has gone to that point that even that's
done so they need to think of something
else now the best one is when they faked
a [ __ ] uh what's called a trailer
exploding do you guys hear about that
one no no
so this girl she's about to do a scene
she goes into her trailer and it [ __ ]
exists
she dies her partner's supposed to it's
her her homegirl and they're supposed to
do a gang bang as both of them get
[ __ ] but that's her best friend and so
she's bawling
but then the director comes up and goes
you still have to do the scene
they're literally like face [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] her and they're coming
in her face and then the girl comes out
and she goes it's a prank
that's like this
oh my god the girl has like nut all over
her face
and she's mad at her friend and she's
like just he's always like come on
it's the best who is this for he was on
what's that effect it was on that one
yeah
don't don't avoid me he's acting all
surprised he's sobbed
you